Let's look at the solution to our RAID5
quiz, where we had the five disk array
with disks similar to what we've
seen in quizzes before, and
the replacement is 24
hours once the disk fails.
The data capacity for
RAID5 Is just like for RAID4, 800 GB.
Effectively, we still sacrifice one
disk worth of capacity to parity.
It's just that this parity now is
distributed among the five disks.
The throughput for
the five disk array however,
is much better than for a RAID4.
For RAIDs, all of the disks now
have equal amounts of data.
So we can use all five of
them when we want to read.
For writes now, we distribute the parity
accesses among all of the disks.
So all of them can now support writes.
But we need four accesses so we could
be doing what needs to be done for
writes at 50 MB per second throughput.
But what needs to be done for
writes is four accesses.
We need to read the data and the parity,
and then update the data and the parity.
So we do four accesses for
every write, which means that our
write throughput is going to be
one fourth of what we can do.
Just like before, that means that for
one-fifth of a second we will be
doing what reads need to do, and for
the four-fifths of a second will we be
doing what writes need to do in order to
achieve the same number of reads and
writes.
Because reads take a quarter
of the time that writes do.
That means that in our
one-fifth of a second,
we will do ten megabytes of reads,
and then in the remaining
four-fifths of that second will
do ten megabytes of writes.
That way we achieve the same
amount of reads and writes, and
the overall throughput is
20 megabytes per second.
This is much better than in RAID4.
Finally, our MTTF here for RAID5 is
exactly the same as it was for RAID4.
It is the MTTF of one
disk divided by five.
This is how long we have
until one of the disks fails.
Times how many times can we
attempt a repair until we
finally experience a failure of one of
the remaining four disks in this array.
So this part here is really the expected
lifetime of the four disks,
left to their own devices.
And this is the MTTR.
And what we get is the same
number here as we did for
Raid4 which is 20,833,333
hours which is more
than 2,000 years again.
So Raid5 has the same data capacity and
the MTTF as RAID 4, but
has significantly better throughput.
For reads, it has slightly better
throughput because we can use
all five disks instead of just four.
For writes it has a lot
better throughput.
So that means that we never really
want to use a RAID4 array because we can
move to a RAID5 array without
sacrificing data capacity,
without sacrificing the MTTF, but
with improving the throughput.